put your mask on
put your mask on
yo hold up you know what i'm mark please
who why you always mess with people's
name i mess up words you mess up
people's name long beach griffin
i'm mark please because griffins are
more cool than griffey's no i don't beat
these griffy listen to all my nerd fans
griffins are cooler than griffins aren't
we lying
griffin that's that's a that's an eagle
animal
excuse for imr please
well listen there's more keys
and there's more clicks
no no no no no no the l makes it a
little bit softer mark you always mess
up names man it's just fine well i mean
yeah yeah i could call you by your name
or i'll call you peaches
people already call me peaches let's go
cause peaches is sweet
add some cream pizza cream that's gay
puff do not be toxic
ever since that jubilee video i've been
trying to undo
some of my fertilizer
to be more accommodating of the l
g
g g we have a remix of this in no time
and [ __ ] we're going to feature your
caring ass
hear the music
put your mask on
put your mask on
put your mask on
put your mask
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lets go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everything right now and go check all
the beats they're all fire all of them
that's right listen if you think what he
did with us was great you need to go see
some of his other stuff hobby listen
everything is great listen
it's amazing over there i've been a fan
of his for a long time you know what i
mean being [ __ ] what he does so when
he did this for us i was like damn you
know give me a bit of that be more
energy it's cold oh yeah oh yeah yeah he
went jersey on him yeah hey he went in
jersey on him yeah he went he went he
went yeah
it's
thank you
thank you very much holy spirit activate
holy spirit activate holy spirit
activate activate activate holy spirit
activate holy spirit yo listen all of
your beats fire
it's all
if you're a fan of memes he takes all
the video memes that you have there's a
lot of great stuff we don't watch it
just go watch it link in the description
thank you the people comment that [ __ ]
is good fire all right let us know in
the comments listen
comments winning yes my dude
jeez we never lie to you guys we told
you a remix was coming
you're welcome